if you're visiting Hong Kong here are
some iconic places you've probably seen
in the movies now shamshree Paul is
known for their awesome food and
handmade crafts but did you know that
this is also a very popular spot for
films if you walk around you might spot
that this location is where they shot
Transformers age of Extinction and we
couldn't help but to pretend to run away
from the Decepticons as well our next
stop is a small little shop called space
audio where you will find tube
amplifiers and Hi-Fi systems now if you
guessed it right this is from the movie
Inferno Affairs this is the exact place
where Andy Lau and Tony long were
listening to music and the best part is
that we got to listen to the original
soundtrack as well
[Music]
now we were so impressed and so amazed
to check out these places and there are
plenty more things to see and do here in
Hong Kong so follow us for more
Adventures